>> Phoebe Connelly: Good
afternoon, I'm Phoebe Connelly,
the deputy director of video
at the Washington Post.
We are a charter sponsor of
the National Book Festival.
I'd like to start by
thanking the co-chairman
of the festival David Rubenstein
and the other generous sponsors
who have made this
event possible.
If you'd like to become
a financial supporter,
please note the information
to how to do
that is part of your program.
We'll also have time after the
presentation for your questions,
and I've been asked to remind
you that if you do come
to the microphone, you will
be included in video tape
of the event, which may be
broadcast at a later date.
So, I am delighted to
introduce our guest today,
Jessica Kensky and
Patrick Downes.
They were married in 2012
and were injured during the
Boston Marathon Bombing in 2013.
Their dog, Rescue,
is also on stage.
Rescue joined their family
several months later.
They're going to speak about
their book "Rescue and Jessica:
A Life-Changing Friendship".
About their first
picture book they say,
"We hope this story inspires you
to celebrate others in the way
that we have been celebrated.
Making this book has
been therapeutic,
and we hope you enjoy
the story as much
as we enjoyed telling it."
They will also be
signing books at 1:30.
So, without further
ado, our authors.
>> Patrick Downes:
Thank you, Phoebe.
Thank you.
Good morning, everyone,
how are you?
You people in these back
chairs are really missing
out on something, because there
are plenty of bean bags upfront.
You kids picked the right spot.
We are going to read for you
our book "Rescue and Jessica:
A Life-Changing Friendship".
It is very important
for you all to know
that this is the real Rescue.
That's him from the book
here with you today.
Yeah, he'll accept
a round of applause.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
Sometimes, he'll need a little
encouragement throughout this
presentation, so
applause is welcome,
and this woman right
here is the real Jessica.
>> Jessica Kensky: Hi.
>> Patrick Downes: This
is her from the book.
We're going to read
this story for you,
and then at the end we want
to hear your questions,
your comments, if you
have a favorite page.
We're going to show you
some of the amazing things
that Rescue can do, and we're
going to make this as fun
as you would like it to be.
Sound good?
>> Jessica Kensky: Yeah.
>> Patrick Downes: All
right, let's start.
That's Rescue as a puppy.
It's pretty cute.
On a special farm
in the countryside a pup
named Rescue was in training.
He was learning to help people
who could not see,
but he was worried.
His trainer had just
said, "You aren't meant
to be a seeing eye dog."
That was hard for
Rescue to hear.
Helping people who can't
see was the family business.
"The service dog team is better
for you," his trainer said.
Service dogs work beside
their partners instead
of in front of them.
"Will I be a good service dog?"
Rescue wondered.
"What will my new
partner be like?
Will she like me?"
that is Rescue's real voice.
Rescue didn't want
to let anyone down.
In a hospital in the city a
girl named Jessica was worried.
Both of her legs
were badly hurt.
Everyone hoped the right leg
would heal, but the doctors had
to remove part of her left leg,
so she could be healthy again.
"You're an amputee now,
Jessica," the doctor explained.
"You have to wear a prosthetic
leg or use a wheelchair
for the rest of your life."
That was hard to hear.
She had only ever walked
on her own two legs.
"How will I do things
on my own?"
Jessica wondered.
"When will I be able
to walk again?
What will my life be like?"
Her whole family was
worried about her,
and she didn't want
to let anyone down.
Back in the country,
Rescue was learning how
to be a service dog.
When he wore his blue cape,
that meant he was in training.
He had to stay by
his partner's side.
He fetched all kinds of things.
He even learned how
to open doors.
"Rescue, you are a
natural," said his trainer.
At the hospital --
we can welcome people up on
the stage too if they'd like.
At the hospital Jessica was
learning new ways to do things
that used to come easily.
She used a wheelchair
to get around.
She practiced getting
out of bed differently.
She put on prosthetic
leg, so she could stand.
She was learning
how to walk again,
even though her right
leg was still hurt.
"Jessica, you are becoming
strong," said her doctors.
Rescue was proud of all
he had accomplished,
but he still worried.
He was named in honor
of a brave firefighter.
He had big shoes to fill.
Rescue wanted to help people
just like his namesake.
Jessica knew she had
made a lot of progress,
but she was frustrated and sad
about the things she
still couldn't do.
She wondered if she would
ever be happy again.
She felt like the changes
were too big, too much.
One day, a visitor
came to see Jessica
and she brought her
service dog Curry.
Jessica saw how a smart dog
like Curry could help her.
That very day she started
filling out the application
to ask for a dog of her own.
After a while Jessica gets
some very exciting news.
Rescue got exciting news too.
He also got a new red cape.
Finally, the big day arrived.
"It's nice to meet you,
Rescue," said Jessica.
"She looks nice and so
pretty," Rescue thought.
Rescue stood up very tall.
He hopes she didn't notice
his legs were trembling
but his wagging tail give away.
Jessica smiled a big smile
and laughed a big laugh
for the first time
in a long time.
Jessica and Rescue stayed in
the country for a few weeks,
and Rescue showed her all
the things he could do.
"You're amazing,"
Jessica told Rescue.
"You think I'm amazing?"
Rescue thought, "I
think you're amazing."
Back in the city Rescue
and Jessica get used
to working together.
Rescue brought her
the things she needed.
He opened things that
are hard for her reach.
Rescue barked if
Jessica needed someone.
If she tripped, he
would hold steady,
so she could get back up.
Rescue and Jessica
were always together,
but when she didn't
need his help,
Rescue really liked to sleep.
That's why we bring the tent.
Jessica knew that even though
Rescue was special he was a
regular dog too.
She made sure that Rescue
had playtime every day,
but Jessica still wasn't
completely healthy.
One day her doctor told her
that her right leg would
have to be removed too.
She would need to
wear prosthetic legs.
This didn't get any
easier for Jessica to hear.
The night after the doctor
removed her right leg,
Rescue knew just what to do to
help Jessica all on his own.
Rescue and Jessica had
to start all over again.
Slowly, but surely, they learned
all the things they needed
to do together.
They did choirs together, played
together, and they were so good
at snuggling together.
For the first time in a long
time Jessica felt happy,
and that made Rescue happy too.
"You changed my life,
Rescue," she said,
"I couldn't have done
this without you."
"I'm so proud of
us," he thought.
"You rescued me,
Rescue," said Jessica,
but the truth was they
had rescued each other.
The end.
[ Applause ]
So, who is going to be the brave
first one to ask a question,
have a comment, tell us
about their favorite page?
Is the [inaudible]
guitar, does that count?
What's your question
or comment, Sir?
This gentleman is very astute.
He noticed in the book
that there's a little boy.
Are we able to pull
the pages back up?
Thank you.
There's that boy
on the left-hand
of the screen next
to the refrigerator.
Does that boy look
like someone to you?
It looks like me?
How do you know he
looks like me?
Because someone told you?
You had some insight
information.
I thought you were going to say
because of his boyish
charm or his good looks.
No, just someone told you.
Yeah, that's understandable.
>> Jessica Kensky: So, there's
a lot of hidden Easter eggs
in our book that our
illustrator Scott Magoon put in.
So, our friend, Scott, who drew
all these amazing pictures,
and one of the many Easter eggs
is that is a little Patrick.
In real life Patrick
and I are married,
and in real life I
was actually a grownup
when the story was
happening, but for lots
of reasons we decided to draw --
have Jessica shown
as the technical term,
I'm told, is a tween.
Do you guys know any
tweens, any almost-teenagers?
So, because I was a teenager,
I couldn't really be married
in the book, and
Patrick was a little sad.
He felt kind of left out,
and so we've got a
little Patrick in there.
Another Easter egg is that
in almost every scene,
what do you guys
notice that Rescue
or that little Patrick
is carrying?
That's a great one.
A firetruck.
[Inaudible]
>> Patrick Downes: Sorry.
If we remember from the story,
Rescue is named after a brave--
>> Jessica Kensky: Firefighter.
>> Patrick Downes: Firefighter,
and when we were hurt,
brave firefighters came
to help us and save us,
and so this is our
way to say thank you
to all the special
firefighters in our lives.
Yeah, excellent question.
Thanks for being so
brave to kick it off.
Yes, Ma'am?
So, she would like to know
what happened to my leg.
Jessica and I were
hurt at the same time.
We had just been married.
We were at the Boston Marathon.
Has anyone ever been to a
marathon or a road race?
They're really fun, right?
Lots of energy, lots of
amazing people running very far
distances, and in Boston it's
the best day of the year.
It's Patriot's Day, and
so everyone gets work off,
no one goes to school,
and your job is
to either run the marathon
or go and cheer everyone on,
and that's where we were.
We got hurt at the same time.
She would like to
know how we got hurt.
Unfortunately, two really mean
people decided to hurt us.
They created a bomb,
which made an explosion,
which hurt our legs and
hurt a lot of other people,
but the most incredible
part from that day isn't
that a bomb went off, it
was all these amazing people
who ran toward us to help us,
the brave firefighters, yes.
[ Applause ]
We had these brave firefighters.
We had people with no training.
We had police offers, nurses,
doctors, EMTs ran toward us
to help us, so that
we could be healthy
and be with you here today.
It's pretty amazing.
Thanks for asking
those brave questions.
Yes, dear?
What's your question?
You've read this book before?
Where did you read it?
At home? Wow, you must have
some special people at home
to bring this kind of
book into your house.
What did you think
of it the first time?
It was great?
And, what did you think
about it this time?
It was awesome, okay.
This is an important -- I'm
glad you brought this up.
So, anyone who has the book at
home or in their classroom needs
to make sure that whoever reads
the book uses a Rescue voice.
It has to be high-pitched
and loud
and as goofy as possible, okay?
So, make sure that
happens next time.
>> Jessica Kensky: I
think we have a question
of the microphone
over here, Honey.
>> How long did it
take you how to walk?
>> Patrick Downes:
Great question.
>> Jessica Kensky: That's
a really good question.
So, just like in the book,
I had to learn how to walk
on one prosthetic, and then the
doctor said you need a second
prosthetic leg, so
I had to learn how
to walk on two prosthetics.
I would say it took me two
years to be able to walk
and you know what one of
the hardest things is to do,
as an amputee, which
is what we're called,
amputees, standing.
So, to stand on this
stage and pretend
like I'm casually talking to
you guys today is really hard.
I'm using all kinds of
muscles to stand and balance
when I can't feel
the ground anymore.
So, I'd say it took me
about two years and Patrick?
>> Patrick Downes:
Like a year and a half.
>> Jessica Kensky: And, the
thing is we have to practice
and keep trying hard every day.
That's probably the
most important thing.
So, that's a great question.
>> Patrick Downes:
Great question.
>> Jessica Kensky: I
think before we run
out of time we want
to wake Rescue up.
>> Patrick Downes: He's
going to need a big noise,
clapping, maybe some yelling.
We got to wake him up.
Come on, buddy.
>> Jessica Kensky: Come on, bud.
Let's do it.
Come on. So, good boy.
I want to show you a couple
of the tasks Rescue
can help me with.
I don't call them trick,
because they're special things,
for the most part, that he
does that help me every day
or he knows how to do
just in case I need him.
One of the most important
things is that Rescue only barks
or talks when I tell him to
or when he's having
free time, his recess.
So, if I had a bad fall at
home and Patrick wasn't home
and I couldn't get up
and I needed help --
we live in an apartment
and our neighbors know
if you hear Rescue bark, will
you please come check on me.
So, if I had a bad fall, I
could say, "Rescue, speak."
Speak. That's pretty
good, right?
Pretty loud.
If he's barking and barking
and barking and no one's home
and no one's hearing us, he has
a command to find my cellphone.
So, there's a little
bit of vanilla extract
on the back of the cellphone.
So, when I tell him
to find my phone,
he's going to bring
anything that smells
like vanilla extract, which
your mom or dad or brothers
or sister might bake with it,
and I can't smell it
anymore, but he still can.
So, we're going to
see how he does today,
because there's all kinds of
new smells and sounds in here,
but if I, again, had a bad fall,
it's an emergency, I need help,
I'd say, "Rescue, fetch phone."
Go closer, closer, give.
>> Patrick Downes:
How about that.
>> Jessica Kensky: Good boy.
[ Applause ]
There's also just a
general term for fetch.
So, just like in the book,
sometimes I'm in a wheelchair,
sometimes I'm on crutches,
sometimes I'm like today,
where I have both prosthetics
on, and if I'm out somewhere
with -- he found the cookies.
Rescue [inaudible].
He's a very good dog,
but he's still a dog.
So, I I drop something, I
could bend down and pick it up,
but I might lose my balance.
He's -- he really
wants a cookie.
He didn't even wait.
Good boy, bud.
So, the general term is
fetch, and that just can be
for anything on the ground.
He'll start with the
closest things to me
and then move further away.
So, if I have a really
messy bedroom,
which sometimes I still do,
he might bring me a couple
things off the floor before he
brings me maybe the one
thing that I really want,
because it's just a
general term for fetch,
and then we'll show you.
This one was actually one of his
hardest ones, believe it or not.
Rescue, come here.
Over here, come here, down.
Ready, down, roll over.
He's going to -- that -- very--
>> Patrick Downes:
Gravity defying stunts.
>> Jessica Kensky: Should
we do the [inaudible] one?
>> Patrick Downes: Yeah.
>> Jessica Kensky: And,
these ones are obviously more
for cuteness, but cuteness
ones are important too.
Rescue, say your prayers.
Good boy, and then,
Rescue, come here.
Give me a hug.
Tell me a secret.
He said he's very exciting
you all came out today.
So, those are just a few
of the things that Rescue
in real life can do, everything
we show you he does in the book.
>> Patrick Downes: We have time
for about one, maybe,
two questions.
Yes?
You've read the book before too?
We came to your classroom?
To Lafayette?
How did we do that time?
You don't know.
Did you learn anything
new from the story today?
No, you picked up
everything the first time.
You must be smart.
Yes, dear?
How long did it take
to train Rescue?
Great question.
>> Jessica Kensky: So,
Rescue started training,
just like in the picture,
when he was a tiny puppy.
He was eight weeks old, and it
took him from eight weeks old
to 18 months old
for him to get his,
what color cape did he
get when he graduated?
A red cape.
So, it took almost two years,
and at that point Rescue
and I matched, and I had to go
to his school, because I had
to learn everything
Rescue already knew.
So, we worked together for
about two weeks at that point.
>> Patrick Downes: We are going
to do a signing after this.
If you get our book,
you get your own special
pawtograph [phonetic].
This paw is in a stamp,
and we'll put it right
inside your book,
so that Rescue signs your book.
>> Jessica Kensky:
And, it is authentic.
It is his real paw print.
>> Patrick Downes: Yes.
>> Jessica Kensky: Well, yeah.
>> Patrick Downes:
We're so honored
to have been here
with all of you.
Thank you for your
questions and curiosity.
Have a great day.
>> Jessica Kensky: Thank you.